et les envoyer à l'opérateur du télescope,
et attendre avec impatience le retour des données,
tout en priant les dieux de la météorologie.
Je parie que vous n'avez pas de carrière
qui dépende fondamentalement du fait qu'il faisait nuageux la nuit dernière.
Nous n'allions pas avoir de deuxième chance.
Comme le temps était parfait, ‘Oumuamua a décidé de ne pas l'être.
Sa luminosité n'était pas constante.
Ici, nous voyons ‘Oumuamua filer entre les étoiles.
Elle est au milieu.
Les étoiles n'apparaissent pas parce que le télescope suit son déplacement.
Elle était faible puis lumineuse, faible, lumineuse, et faible encore,
comme la lumière du soleil réfléchie sur quatre faces d'un objet oblong.
L'extrême variation de luminosité
nous a menés à une conclusion inévitable à propos de sa forme.
Comme ce rendu d'artiste le montre ici,
‘Oumuamua est apparemment très long et étroit,
avec un rapport axe d'environ 10 pour 1.
En supposant qu'il est sombre, il devrait donc faire environ 800 mètres de long.
Rien d'autre dans notre système solaire ne ressemble à ça.
Seule une poignée d'objets possèdent un rapport d'axe
plus grand que 5 pour 1.
Nous ne savons pas comment il a été formé,
mais cela pourrait provenir de sa création dans son système solaire natal.
La luminosité d'‘Oumuamua variait toutes les 7,34 heures,
du moins c'est ce que nous croyions,
car les données fournies par les autres équipes
rapportaient des chiffres différents.
Comment expliquer que plus on en apprend,
plus il est difficile d'interpréter ?
Il s'avèra que la rotation de ‘Oumuamua n'était pas ordinaire.
La comète oscillait comme une toupie.
Pendant qu'elle tourne autour de son petit axe,
elle tourne aussi autour de son long axe
et oscille de haut en bas.
Ce mouvement très dynamique et rapide
est presque certainement le résultat d'un choc qui l'a violemment éjecté
hors de son système solaire d'origine.
Notre interprétation de sa forme grâce à sa luminosité
dépend très sérieusement de la façon dont elle tourne,
nous devons donc repenser ce à quoi elle pourrait ressembler,
et comme le montre cette belle toile de l'artiste spatial Bill Hartmann,
la forme de ‘Oumuamua serait plutôt, à notre avis, celle d'un ovale aplati.
Revenons aux énergétiques.
De quoi est-elle faite ?
Dans l'idéal, nous adorerions avoir un morceau de ‘Oumuamua
au laboratoire afin de pouvoir l'étudier en détail.
Comme il est impossible même pour une entreprise privée de lancer
un engin spatial en une semaine
vers quelque chose comme ça,
les astronomes dépendent d'observations à distance.
Les astronomes observent l'interaction entre la lumière et la surface.
Certaines couleurs peuvent être absorbées, leur donnant une empreinte chimique,
tandis que d'autres couleurs ne le seront pas.
D'autre part, il se peut que certaines substances réfléchissent la couleur bleue
ou rouge avec plus d'efficacité.
Dans le cas de ‘Oumuamua, elle réfléchit mieux la lumière rouge,
ce qui ressemble à la riche surface organique d'une comète récemment visitée
par la sonde spatiale Rosetta.
Mais tout ce qui est rouge en apparence n'a pas forcément la même composition.
De fait, les minéraux contenant de petits morceaux de fer à la surface
peuvent aussi sembler rouges,
tout comme le côté obscur de Japet, la lune de Saturne,
comme le montrent ces images prises par la sonde Cassini.
Les météorites en fer, ou métal,
peuvent aussi avoir l'air rouges.
Bien que nous ne sachions pas ce qui est à la surface,
nous en savons encore moins sur ce qui est à l'intérieur.
Toutefois, nous savons qu'elle doit être suffisamment solide
pour ne pas voler en éclats en tournant.
Sa densité est probablement similaire à celle d'un astéroïde rocheux ;
peut-être même plus dense, comme le métal.
Je veux au moins vous montrer
l'une des plus belles images en couleur
prises par l'un des télescopes terrestres.
D'accord, je l'admets, ce n'est pas si spectaculaire.
(Rires)
Nous n'avons juste pas la résolution nécessaire.
Même avec le télescope spatial Hubble,
la vue n'est pas bien meilleure.
Mais l'importance des données d'Hubble n'était pas due aux images,
mais parce qu'il a allongé notre temps d'observation
jusqu'à deux mois et demi après la découverte,
en ayant d'autres positions le long de son orbite,
qui, je l'espère, vont nous aider à déterminer d'où provient ‘Oumuamua.
Mais qu'est-ce que ‘Oumuamua, exactement ?
Nous croyons sincèrement à la possibilité d'avoir découvert un reste archéologique
du processus de formation d'un autre système planétaire,
une sorte de bois flottant céleste.
Certains scientifiques pensent que ‘Oumuamua se serait formé
très près d'une étoile plus dense que la nôtre,
et que les forces de marée ont broyé des matériaux planétaires
au tout début du système solaire.
D'autres suggèrent encore que c'est un objet qui se serait formé
pendant l'agonie mortelle d'une étoile,
peut-être lors de l'explosion d'une supernova,
en même temps que le broyage de matériaux planétaires.
Quoi qu'il puisse être, nous pensons que c'est un objet naturel,
mais nous ne pouvons pas prouver que ce n'est pas un objet artificiel.
La couleur, la forme étrange, le mouvement de culbutage
pourraient tous avoir d'autres explications.
Même si nous ne croyons pas que c'est une technologie extraterrestre,
pourquoi ne pas faire l'expérience logique et rechercher un signal radio ?
C'est exactement ce que le projet Breakthrough Listen a fait,
mais jusqu'ici, ‘Oumuamua reste absolument silencieuse.
Pourrait-on envoyer un engin spatial vers ‘Oumuamua
et répondre à cette question une fois pour toute ?
Oui, nous avons la technologie nécessaire,
mais ce serait un voyage long et coûteux,
et nous nous éloignerions tellement du Soleil
que la trajectoire d'approche finale serait très compliquée.
Je pense que ‘Oumuamua a beaucoup d'autres choses à nous apprendre,
et en fait, il pourrait y avoir plus de surprises
pendant que des scientifiques comme moi continuent à étudier les données.
Plus important encore, je pense que ce lointain visiteur
a vraiment confirmé le fait que notre système solaire n'est pas isolé.
Nous faisons partie d'un milieu bien plus grand,
et en effet, nous pourrions bien être entourés de visiteurs interstellaires
sans même le savoir.
Ce cadeau inattendu
a peut-être soulevé plus de questions qu'il n'a apporté de réponses
mais nous avons été les premiers à saluer un visiteur d'un autre système solaire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Jedidah : Merci, Karen.
J'ai beaucoup apprécié cette conférence. Merci.
Comme nous l'avons découvert tardivement dans son trajet vers nous,
les technologies futures telles que le Large Synoptic Survey Telescope
détecteront-elles ces objets plus tôt ?
Karen Meech : Oui. Nous espérons continuer de voir beaucoup de ces objets.
Dans l'idéal, nous aimerions en découvrir un dans sa trajectoire vers le Soleil
pour avoir le temps de faire tous les tests scientifiques,
ou encore mieux,
avoir un engin spatial prêt à décoller,
garé quelque part en position L4 ou L5;
proche de la Terre,
pour que lorsqu'un objet s'approche, nous puissions le suivre.
JL : Génial, merci beaucoup. Remercions encore Karen.
(Applaudissements)